donald trump appeared on milk boys full
senpai and then it got pulled off
youtube how many of you said before
five minutes like five million in 24
hours
yeah
i mean
for misinformation in the bag
immediately apparently youtube pulled it
off because trump claimed that the
election was fraudulent yeah and youtube
has an anti-like election like they have
like an election integrity policy
that he broke
so that's why i got pulled off i wonder
if he can use like a little bit more
specific language to get away with that
because he could say
there was fraud in the election because
there's fraud in every election yeah
he just
can't say that the fraud changed the
results
do you know what i'm saying right
every election right think about it like
every election there's going to be some
like
there like an old lady that writes in
her husband that just passed away his
vote as well yeah so that technically is
fraud yeah
it's just not enough to actually
overturn an election i'm not saying i'm
right i want you to tell me why i'm
wrong yeah there was a lot of left-wing
people who said the trump election was
kind of stolen because the only reason
trump won is russian misinformation and
russian bots etc or whatever that word
is how is that different and how is that
acceptable if you said that would you
still get pulled off ooh
that's a good that's hey that's good
because if so and this is the i don't
necessarily think free speech should
always be allowed you can't say i'm
gonna kill the president and get away
with it that should be punished well but
i guess the only thing i would say to
that is
those people were influenced by
information but they still voted i think
what trump is saying is that there were
fake votes yeah they were sent in and
those are different things like
influencing someone into voting it's
like yeah you found a i guess a loophole
in the system right but the same like
russia can send a million
videos saying how awesome a candidate is
if you don't get up off your ass and go
vote then right right it's also
difference between saying
the referees didn't do a good job
and
that team didn't win that game like
trump sort of goes after the actual
outcome being like this is a legitimate
he says the game was fixed as opposed to
the refs
yeah the ref sucked yeah i mean that
[ __ ] was getting taken down no matter
what yeah yeah there's no question it's
just wild times like
that that even happens yeah i mean he's
a president i mean there was
ex-president have you seen any of the
clips yeah have you seen the clip of him
talking about how he's a he's like a
good dj yeah the ymca yeah you know what
gets the people going ymca
the gay national anthem he called it the
gay national anthem
yeah he's just the most entertaining off
on the windmills he's like oh these
windmills why are they building these
windmills what's the point of these ones
i tell them all the time they don't work
they're ugly but these people love the
windmill it's like there's a war
happening he's just waxing about
windmills this is amazing it's so funny
yeah
yeah i wonder
you see this conversation happen all the
time it's like are does russia invade
ukraine if trump is still president
i think so
yeah i i don't remember trump having a
real i've heard he did a good job with
china yeah kind of checking china but i
did not hear that about russia
i would hear kind of the opposite again
who knows what side i'm hearing
information from yeah it's very safe to
say that i don't know and i don't think
any of us know yeah
we might find out
i don't think until we know fully why
russia invaded and what the exact reason
was like in five years will we know if
they would do it when trump is present
like if it's just if it's desperation
they're gonna do it no matter who's if
it's fear of nato expansionism like that
was happening regardless so it might
have just happened anyway if it was
like if it's these bio labs or whatever
like russia is a legend yeah like that
was still going on so maybe it would
have happened yeah it's like i don't
know we can't know until we know where
the actual motivation is and you have to
understand like what trump's policy
would be in the area right so if trump
is like yo cut this nato expansion out
then there might not be any reason yeah
for putin to get get to work who knows
um
yeah it's now boys have been doing a
good job
yeah they've been doing a really good
job they're plugged in and i think they
do it all without like any monetization
directly from adsense on so they're just
doing it for the merch business yeah
interesting
really
crazy wow yeah because i think they got
their monetization removed
yeah
they're wild boys yeah they're wild boys
yes they are yeah yeah they've been
doing a good job like getting really
like marquee guests at the right time
like they had antonio brown right in the
middle of that whole scandal like they
keep having and they keep like using
these relationships that they already
have built up
and working them brilliantly like
getting dana white on there like i mean
it's just
yeah they're doing a great job now
something i'm curious about how come the
white house hasn't briefed us about the
war in ukraine we're not important
enough they've been briefing everyone
else they're briefing all these tick
tockers but they haven't even maybe they
know that we got it down
uh
we're saying nuke everyone yeah they're
like all right like yeah that's what we
were gonna tell the tick tockers yeah
they're keeping it up yeah
maybe they should call us to talk to the
tick tockers maybe i think we should be
on the phone with addison right be like
hey listen
push the button all right yeah we gotta
do the nuke challenge whatever i saw
that though like when i saw that they
were like uh briefing the tick-tock and
stuff like that
my my immediate reaction was like ugh
how nice would it be to learn on this
about on tick-tock like i i want it on
youtube 100 like give me
a great idea yeah and it's kind of the
only way to fight the propaganda war
because you know the other side is going
to put out their [ __ ] yeah so you got to
tell your people hey here's what the
deal is get it out to how many a billion
people on tick tock yeah or or do you
want us to watch jen sackey
on cnn at 2pm it's not happening yo you
gotta you gotta adapt adapt and get hey
let's get the information out how out
however gets out
yeah 100 why would you say no to it it
just sounds so ridiculous it sounds it
sounds embarrassing but we are
embarrassing as a culture culture tends
to be embarrassing there's this kid who
breaks down um like historical events
but he does them kind of sarcastically
on tick tock
and uh it's great like i feel like i'm
learning about it yeah it's just like
the best teacher ever and i feel like
i'm learning about this thing that
happened in american history and he's
breaking it down and i'm kind of like
laughing at it and i'm like yeah this
should be all learning it's hamilton
this is what happens when america
doesn't control the platform
because like back when america
controlled the platform they're like all
right let's call up dorsey college
zuckerberg and like we'll brief them on
the war in ukraine and now the china's
running they're like we gotta tell the
content creators right tell them how to
run it because
u.s companies we can do at the
algorithmic level yeah
you do it the right way
china's not telling their influencers
how to do it they're like yeah this is
what they're going to do it's like doing
brand deals versus just promoting
rankings now we have to integrate it
directly into the person speaking yeah
exactly
and so that's how we have to influence
it through the manual algorithm of the
credit we can't just turn up the knobs
you